hey we are a small snippet of squanch
games and we are here to
tell you how excited we are to be a part
of the microsoft games show extended
showcase extended you know oh game
showcase extended
what what's the need for the extended
why add that extra words
like is there one that's not extended
and that's why we're getting nods there
is a there is a not extended one okay
and that one's just called without the
extended
so that's just uh there's the normal one
i know what this is well hey look we're
happy to be a part of it nonetheless
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is a moment
[Music]
[Applause]
this is
[Music]
it's is to rise
[Music]
welcome to xbox game showcase extended
i'm aaron this is malik and we have the
honor of diving deeper into some of the
most exciting and talked about
announcements as well as gameplay from
the xbox and bethesda games showcase
just two days ago for the first time
ever the entire showcase was focused on
games you can play over the next 12
months that's right aaron you saw world
premiere gameplay from redfall and
starfield and today we've got bethesda's
own pete hines right here to tell us
more you'll hear from the renowned
developers behind the brand new xbox
franchise our history untold dive into
naraka bladepoint with our partners at
netease games and so much more but first
we begin with a special look at how our
fans got to celebrate the xbox and
bethesda games showcase with a message
from our very own phil spencer
[Music]
i love coming to events like this you
just feel the energy people loving to
come together as a community their love
of video games the xbox fans just a
really special time for everybody myself
included
gaming has this unique ability to bring
people together whether it's saving the
world from the aliens or winning a
football game it's so great
[Music]
i love hearing from people what did you
like in the show those conversations
with people that are here about areas
that they like in areas they wish we'd
do more i think that's something that
drives us you saw it in the show today
people said we want to see more gameplay
and so we said okay great you're gonna
see a ton of gameplay yeah you know i
think this is our biggest lineup ever in
terms of just diversity of different
kinds of games from different kinds of
teams different genres there's some
franchises japanese franchises don't
always come to xbox we've been working
on that today we obviously had persona
it's you know important to us we not
only have all the games coming from our
internal studios but also great
independent game developers that we work
with around the world so could not be
more excited for what we're doing with
kojima and he's got this really great
idea for a game i want to be clear
because i know we say like experience
and stuff he's building a video game but
he has this real unique things that he
wants to do in the game and we said okay
let's go do something together and i'm
just really proud to be in an industry
that can be part of so many people
coming together
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bethesda opened the showcase with a
dramatic gameplay demo for red fall and
closed it with todd howard showing us
how deep the rabbit hole goes on
starfield and we also got a sneak peek
at upcoming expansions for elder scrolls
online and fallout 76 here to break it
all down for us is the man the myth
legend himself pete hines from bethesda
pete how are you i'm great good to see
you good to see you as well so about a
month ago you all announced some delays
for both redfall and starfield so i
wanted to give you a chance to like tell
us a little bit about the
decision-making process for that
absolutely look with all the time that
goes into a game it would be foolish to
rush it out the door before it's ready i
think we have continued to sort of
examine how we think about
games and making sure that they are
going to meet our players expectations
obviously the last two years have really
challenged us from a development
standpoint
how we work now
largely remotely while a lot of our
folks are not back in the office and you
know that has an impact i i also think
we've been thinking about things like
release dates and when do we give those
out and and how do we make sure we give
one out that uh that we actually hit and
don't have to change later so um it's
not something we undertake lightly but
at the end of the day i think what our
fans expect what xbox fans what bethesda
fans expect is a is a high quality game
and and we want to do everything we can
to give our teams the time to to fully
realize the the games they're making
yeah and i think that's what it's all
about right like delivering an amazing
experience for the players out there and
so speaking of games we're just going to
jump into it we're going to start with
how the showcase started which sounds
good red fall now before we even get
into the game arcane is making the game
and i want you to talk a little bit
about the pedograph arcane just in case
people don't know sure these folks over
there they're doing their their thing
arcane studios is known for really
amazing immersive uh sims they they do
any number of things
if you if you play games of theirs
dishonored dishonored to pray there's a
lot of common threads you'll find in
them they create really amazing
believable worlds i think that's a big
part of their game is is when you're in
dunwall or you're up on a space station
and pray that it it feels believable
there's a reason why things are the way
they are they're also a big believers in
systems base as opposed to scripted so
they they really embrace player freedom
and sort of giving players the tools to
decide you figure out how you want to
complete this mission or get through
this area we're not going to tell you
how we're just going to give you tools
and then give you the freedom to go and
do but you know there's great characters
an interesting story they bring a lot of
different elements and then really let
the player create the experience they
want and that's what it's all about
gamers have taken many games and made it
their own and i think the fact that
arcane is making the game with that in
mind is super important now how similar
or dissimilar would you say this game
redfall is from the other i mean look on
the surface it's a first person shooter
that you can play solo or with you know
up to four players and so immediately
you might say well it's not a single
player game so it must be wildly
different and and don't get me wrong
there's absolutely ways in which it is
different but i think when folks play
the game and even when they see more of
the game i think they'll start to see
all those things about an arcane game
that they that they love and appreciate
you know why it's won multiple action
game of the year awards for dishonor for
dishonored 2 is their ability to to
bring all of those things together
really high level of polish and and let
folks experience it and so i think all
those things we talked about if you want
to play a game by yourself and get a
great arcane story you can absolutely do
that in red fall but you can also do
things that you haven't been able to do
in an arcane game like experience it
with friends and and find out sort of
how the whole can become greater than
the sum of the parts like playing it off
of each um character's abilities you saw
some of that in the demo we showed you
know that i think the more the people
appreciate that you almost are going to
want to try and play red fall a couple
of different ways you might want to play
it by yourself a little bit play it with
others and it's a game that allows you
to do either or both of those things
however you see fit i'm glad you talked
about playing with friends because i'm
taking applications for friends to help
me get through red fall
can can i put my name on that list
i'm down to a little it'd be an honor
pete keep me on that list all right we
need to go explore red fall together i'm
excited i can't wait for that and so
let's talk a little bit more about the
game now um you know between the trailer
that we saw last year at the reveal as
well as this one that we just saw um i
feel like red fall reminded players of
other co-op shooters like left 4 dead
for example what makes red fall unique
um again it's one of those things like
if you if you watch just like combat
footage you might look at left 4 dead or
back for blood or any of these things
and go oh i see multiple characters
facing a bunch of enemies and like so
it's the same game but i think that's
that would be doing a disservice that
it's all of the things that take place
in between the combat as well as the
combat itself sort of combining
different skills and abilities and in
the way that you do you know layla
dropping down an elevator using her her
powers that jacob can use to get up top
on a on a roof and provide cover you
know you have different characters who
play roles really well how you choose to
use bribone um the robot all of those
things come into again allowing the
players not to say here's a set of rules
and you can only use like no here's just
some stuff that you can go off into this
amazing sort of dynamic ever changing
world and sort of experience and explore
for yourself and you come back the next
day and it'll look and feel like a
different experience even though you're
in the exact same part of the game i
mean i think those are the kinds of
things that arcane does that really um
bring that sort of extra special element
that makes their game so compelling yeah
compelling and fresh so i'm excited for
a red fall and you said it here on for
everyone to see that we're going to be
playing together so i'm going to hold
you to that absolutely
all right can't wait awesome so let's
talk about elder scrolls online now i
wanted to talk about the team philosophy
because i hear that uh the team is
actually banned from saying things like
now is the perfect time to my least
favorite saying is there's never been a
better time to play a game like we all
say that yes games always get better we
know that
the thing that we love about where elder
scrolls online is is is going is their
ability to continually
refresh the experience for players
provide new experiences like going to
high aisle a place they've never been in
an elder scrolls game it does a lot of
things like story and intrigue there's a
lot of politics in high aisle different
factions and and the the conflict that's
going on there and again a way that you
can jump in and play by yourself and
experience it
by yourself even though it's an mmo but
the real special sauce of elder scrolls
online is our amazing community they're
so welcoming they're so helpful you know
if you need a little bit of help if you
need a lot of help
they're there for you to help explain to
you know to make sure you have a fun
experience and honestly like that is
such a huge part for an online game of
creating an environment where anybody no
matter whether you just started playing
or you've been playing for eight years
can have a good experience no matter how
you decide to engage with it i love that
you mentioned that a community is such a
as you mentioned was such a huge part of
any online game and so for players who
may not have played elder scrolls who
are like you said looking to jump in to
know that they have that community
backing them that's going to help them
guide them in their journey is super
exciting so but i want to talk about
fallout a little bit okay huge milestone
recently 25 years of fallout it can rent
a car even now at this point right we're
talking about it all right so this has
to mean something uh super special today
absolutely and and look
we are as aware of anybody like this
this franchise did not start with
bethesda it's one that we took on along
the way and our intent is not just to to
pay homage to like bethesda fallout like
no we mean all fallout because what this
series has done what it what it meant to
us as players when we went and played
those games played the original fallout
fallout 2 um and then what the franchise
has become and sort of growing and
finding an even you know a new audience
with fallout 3 fallout 4 fallout new
vegas fallout 76 is something we really
want to celebrate and honestly that you
know what's going on in fallout 76 with
the pit and your ability to continue to
push the boundaries in an online game of
story and meaningful player choice and
as you're going along making decisions
that kind of
matter and have a real impact i think is
is important in the evolution of fallout
76 and just honestly how far that game
has come from its launch like we're
keenly aware of how that launch went but
we are also keenly aware of the
incredible amount of effort and
dedication from all of our teams across
bethesda to say like we believe in this
thing and we want to give the fans more
of what they want and the kind of
experiences that they want and where
fallout 76 is now is truly remarkable
when you go back and look at sort of
where we were and how far we've come in
and honestly how much cool stuff is in
store in the pit it's it's going to be
super fun excited to jump in and again
that's one of those things that i'm sure
you guys attribute to the community
giving that feedback you know that that
76 community again not just in the game
but
what they do for for each other to
support other folks in the community
what they have done to raise funds for
worthwhile causes like it's not just an
amazing group of gamers it's an amazing
group of human beings and and honestly
one that we're honored to interact with
and be a part of every day i love that
pete before you make me cry we're going
to move on to star field all right okay
all right so let's talk about it
starfield ended the show i gotta say
watching the trailer
breathtaking it's one of those things
from the different locations and just
seeing the difference between that moon
versus the populated city just amazing
the dog fighting uh the just everything
was so awesome the team really outdid
themselves it's one of those things
about a bethesda games studios game that
i always love and it's been the case
honestly since you know i worked on
morrowind and oblivion and all those
games that you know we talked about and
for every single one you cannot pin
people down to oh it's about this
because it's not like ultimately what
those games are are massive sandboxes
where they give players just ridiculous
amounts of freedom to say you go figure
out what kind of game you want to play
and what kind of experience you want to
have because that's what this game is
about it's not us prescribing and saying
you have to do these things and like no
it's about creating this huge
sandbox with over a thousand planets so
you can completely explore and say yeah
but you don't have to like it's entirely
up to you to figure out what what is fun
for me do i want story do i want to join
factions do i want to you know build
outposts and gather resources to build
more cool stuff the team really puts all
of those tools in the player's hands and
step back and says
now it's time for you to tell the story
of starfield which is your story which
is going to be different than mine which
is going to be different than everybody
else's and i think that's that's really
where the magic of a bethesda game
studios game happens speaking about the
scope of everything todd said that this
is what an epic rpg
is what what does bethesda define an
epic rpg as i think again it's it's sort
of leaning into look there's a lot of
folks who take a lot of different
approaches on what is an open world mean
and bethesda game studios always pushes
themselves to the most freedom and least
limitations right where the items in the
world are all real things you walk into
a store and there's a bunch of weapons
or whatever like that's not just art on
a countertop like you could pick those
up you could steal them and run out of
it you can create chaos like we don't
want to put too many limits on what the
player is or isn't allowed to do we love
it when players say i wonder what
happens if and then they try it and then
they get to see like oh my lord chaos
ensued and it was insanity everybody was
shooting at me and like that's i think
the beauty of bethesda game studios and
the and the number of ways that they
push for you to explore that right it's
not just one it's
you could spend thousands of hours doing
nothing but shipbuilding and like focus
that as all you're about and that's okay
but you could also be about exploring
every planet and finding all of the good
and that's okay or you can just play the
main story and be like i want a kind of
experience that i'm guided through so
that i kind of get to see stuff and i
might stop here and there oh there's a
cool side quest that i got but you know
i want something that sort of leads me
through because i'm a little you know it
can be a little daunting to say you can
go do whatever i want like oh i don't
know what i should do so some folks want
a little bit of a guided path or to
understand where the fun is and no
approach is wrong like for me that's
epic because it says we aren't putting
any limits on what you can or can't do
we're gonna set you loose and just sit
back and watch the the beauty that you
create with your own stories and the way
that you solve problems or choose to
spend your time in this world we've
created i love that and i you know what
you said about um you know those moments
that maybe you experience that i don't
like those are some of the best moments
if i think back to playing rpgs when i'm
discussing with my friends oh did you
see that no i didn't see it where did
you see it and having them go out and
find it so i think that's going to be
one of those we talk about that a lot
that sort of water cooler moment like
you come in the next day and you talk to
everybody about what you did and you
were like wait i did that quest but i
did this completely different thing and
you sort of start to appreciate all of
the choices that you could have made you
didn't even realize were an option like
oh i didn't even think about doing that
like oh yeah i just ran in and stole his
ship and shot all of his crew members
and took off like you can do that i'll
go yeah you can do anything like that i
think that is
a special part of the bethesda game
studios game and and when we say epic
rpg we mean all of the stories all of
them all right you just gave me some
ideas for stealing people's ships uh so
i appreciate that uh that's gonna be top
on the list to do in starfield now um we
saw quite a bit of combat and action in
the game that seems to also be in in
addition to exploring and everything
that seems to be another huge focus of
that absolutely i mean you know look if
you look at a game like skyrim which
like everybody's played skyrim at this
point
it can you know a combat is a big part
of that unless you decide it's not like
if you're one of those folks that says
actually i'm going to do the alchemy
thing and i just go off and pick flowers
and make potions and like
live another life in another world this
way then combat isn't part of it but
look we know in an epic rpg there's
always bad people they you know shooting
at you sometimes you got to return fire
and there's a lot of fun to be had there
and so you know providing a lot of
different skills that sort of determine
how good you are in combat combined with
all the different weapons in the game
and then you layer in ship combat and
all these other things it starts to sort
of paint a picture of just how
broad or how deep the rabbit hole goes
it's going to be so impressive um and
you touched on it a little bit and i
want to talk about it because this was
one watching the the video the demo on
what i saw and it really caught my eyes
around the ship um it's not just getting
in the ship and that's your ship there's
so much behind it
a little bit yeah like every ship is
customizable to the nth degree and not
just like cosmetically i want my ship to
look like this or look like that though
obviously that's totally the thing that
you could do if all you care about is
cosmetics but it goes much deeper than
that in terms of like what kind of
shield you have what kind of weapons you
have like what kind of ship are you
building what do you want it to be good
at what trade-offs are you willing to
make or not and then the other part of
it is of course well you can't just like
it's a spaceship those aren't cheap so
you have to figure out like how am i
going to do this where do i get the
resources to build this stuff what kind
of you know skills do i need to level up
to improve different parts of my ship
beyond you know what i could do without
those skills so there's a lot of again
choices in terms of you get to decide
that how much you want to put into that
or not do you just want to give somebody
money for the parts that you want you
want to build it all of those things are
sort of part of the fun of deciding how
much do you want to interact with this
and how do you want to interact with it
absolutely i mean just as you mentioned
the scope the level of player agency
something that i feel like is going to
just make starfield such a special
experience so between red fall esl
fallout 76 and starfield you all are
just
coming yeah we got a few games coming
out it's gonna be so great um pete thank
you so much for stopping by thanks for
having me of course of course pete now
coming up we'll hear from our friends
around the world including squash games
obsidian entertainment playground games
and of course xbox fans like you but
first let's hear from the creators of
one of the world's most popular battle
royale games
[Music]
taja
a unique online multiplayer action game
with players all around the globe
as a net e studio 24 entertainment is
joining hands with microsoft to bring
naraka bladepoint to consoles for the
first time
you could play the game on xbox series x
and s as well as windows next week
we're also joining xbox game pass a
platform with a huge player base and a
vast bright future
naraka has been so well received on the
pc platform
i am so grateful to the players for
their love and support
as a competitive survival game
incorporating a lot of action elements
naraka features a range of characters
with unique personalities
each hero draws from different
civilizations and cultures
battles allow for a great degree of
strategic play you've got a wealth of
melee and ranged weapons to choose from
and a vast map filled with interactive
elements to explore
perhaps you'll engage your foes in
samurai combat katanas at the ready or
maybe you use persian assassin
techniques and strike from afar
with your grappling hook you can fly
between temple walls and across bamboo
forests with ease
beyond solo endeavors you can also party
up with friends and use group tactics to
flatten your foes
that's noraka's underlying design
philosophy that you're unchained and
have the freedom to choose how you play
collect soul jades to change how you
play
transform your katana strikes and make
your cannon a weapon of mass destruction
each hero can be customized too
whether you want to rush into battle as
a berserker warrior
or cast fireballs as a sorcerer the
choice is yours
we can't forget to mention our unique
face customization system too
you'll never need to worry about running
into a doppelganger on the battlefield
because you're able to edit your hero's
features to your heart's content you can
even recreate your favorite faces
as we approach naraka's first launch
anniversary
we're introducing a brand new weapon
the twin blades
releasing together with the xbox and
game pass editions
twin blades strike with the speed of a
raging tempest and sweeping blows
we've seen similar weapons in other
games
but here in naraka it comes with a style
all its own
charging up strikes is usually a high
risk high reward move
with the twin blades you can charge up
while moving and keep your momentum as
you unleash a flurry of combos on foes
since its release naraka bladepoint has
launched its own faction clash game mode
with omni's nightmare and the thrilling
limited time mode shadow surge
there have been many casual modes to
play as well
but our community has eagerly asked for
a campaign mode
we're always listening to our player
base
and we're happy to announce that the
wait is over
players will see the first chapter of
our campaign mode
form teams of three to take on new enemy
types and massive bosses
disarming a boss won't be as easy as
disarming another player though
pvp and campaign mode are two entirely
different games
further campaign chapters are also in
the works so we're eager to hear any
feedback you have for us
we are also working on an xbox one
version and hope to see more players
join naraka later this year
naraka is launching on xbox series xns
and windows store on june 23rd and it's
included with game pass at launch day
now's your chance to dive into the world
of naraka bladepoint
quality
[Music]
[Music]
history is filled with moments of
greatness
some well-known some lost to time
but what about the history that could
have been if you were its architect
how would you reshape the world
what new stories would you tell
and when your people speak
would you listen
how would you lead them in this new
world
[Music]
history is filled with moments of
greatness
but these
will be yours
i'm excited to welcome our friends from
oxide games for a closer look at their
historical grand strategy game for pc
called aura history untold
damn michelle thank you two for joining
us today thank you for having us and on
behalf of the entire studio we are
really excited to be here and finally be
able to talk about rf i mean we all are
excited too you just had the world
premiere two days ago for ara and i have
to say i'm a really really big history
fan i love me some history so i've been
looking forward to talking to you too
about this now we all know this is not
your first strategy game but the vision
behind ara is so ambitious so tell us
more about it and also for those who are
new to oxide games we would love to hear
more about the studio as well so oxide
games was founded nine and a half years
ago in my basement actually
from the development leads of
civilization v and our goal is to push
strategy games to the next level
and what's really great about working on
a new ip is that you don't have kind of
these previous expectations that a
sequel would have and so the sky really
was a limited we got to really take the
genre to a new space and we really hope
that not only will fans of strategy
games like this but people who've never
played a strategy game before will find
something they love as well you're
absolutely taking it to the next level i
think i saw like a drone was in like the
18th century or something like that it's
very very fascinating and i think that
like
if you're someone who really enjoys
history it's bringing like all the
worlds together all the periods of time
together and that's a grand vision in
itself so how does the vision of ara
impact the player experience within the
game so one of the kind of big things we
wanted to do with aura was really
explore
how to make the game less about finding
that optimal strategy that optimal path
and really bring in ways to make it more
meaningful to the player make it unique
to themselves so what are different
kinds of choices we can bring to the
player so that when you play is
different than when i play and yet we
can both be competitive together um how
can we do things to really impact agency
and expression and really let you
express your values and your play styles
through the different mechanics and the
product
and dan what about you how does the
vision impact the overall experience so
one of the big things that we've been
working on is what we call the living
world we wanted uh the expression of the
game to manifest itself in a way that
was feel authentic and cool so we've
spent a lot of effort on making sure
that the choices that you make are
expressed in a visual way and so you're
going to see your citizens doing things
that reflect the choices that you've
made and this is actually really
challenging so one of the goals when we
we founded oxide was to not have to tell
the designers no you can't do that thing
and so the game is obviously huge it's
it's just massive and so it's a very
large technological constraint from
doing something like that but we have
our own proprietary engine that allows
us to really bring this this alternate
earth to life i think that's the beauty
right because in history the great thing
about learning history is that you learn
about culture you learn about stories
you learn about things that are probably
brand new to your eyes but the way that
aura helps you remix reimagine and
rewrite history is a beautiful sight to
see and i'm excited to get my hands on
it and i'm sure everyone else is who's
watching so let us know where can we
learn more about it and when can we get
our hands on it because i need it today
so if you head over to the website you
can sign up for the insider program
which will give you a chance to join the
technical alpha and play the game later
this summer which is super exciting
because we've been playing it you know
all the time and so now you have a
chance to play dan michelle thank you
too so much for giving us the lowdown on
ara really appreciate it thanks for
having us grounded is finally leaving
early access and moving into full
release with a highly anticipated story
mode here's adam breneke and eric
dorabella from obsidian entertainment to
tell us more
[Music]
what can players expect from the 1.0
launch of grounded the big one of course
is going to be a complete game and that
means story right you know from
beginning to end you can play through
you know why are you here who put you
here exactly and how are you gonna get
home i think those are like the big
questions that people are asking about
grounded
originally we really just wanted to make
a survival game and one of the jokes was
hey what if we did backyard survival
everyone was like yeah that's that's a
very unusual idea but i think there's
something there
[Music]
one of the things that we did early on
was establish the art style of grounded
things started like coming to life as we
did the initial prototypes and like
seeing some of the cool things like the
first time we added like the spider into
the yard and seeing the reactions of
people in the office like even like jump
scares like people screaming
the team is very small it's the smallest
team i've ever worked on at obsidian i
wanted everyone to be able to
participate on the design side of things
so i said everyone is a designer on the
team and i think that extends into
our community and how we're building the
game in game preview and early access
that's probably one of the big successes
of the game is how close we work with
the community and take all their
feedback and suggestions i think it's
super rad for a game developer too that
is a
a huge huge thing just to get people's
feedback constantly of what they're
liking what they're not liking and all
those adjustments just make a much much
better game at the end of the day
we're at that point now that the yard is
getting finished and now we can play
through the story there's a lot of
surprises there's a lot of you know
things that i think
players aren't going to expect
and i i think i know what you're talking
about i i cannot wait to see players
reactions
i know a lot of players are just waiting
for the story to be finished to finally
jump into the game people who play the
game previously are also like holding
out for for more content i think it's
just going to pull a lot of people back
in and gain a lot of new players
[Music]
so adam we have the brood mother from
last year was like our first big boss
and then we came out with a bunch of
mini bosses like termite kings or mikey
an assistant manager but in this trailer
uh we're showing players the mantis what
can they expect from this so we're super
excited to finally show off the mantis
and i know that's been a a big ask from
players that they want to see a praying
mantis in the game they've been asking
for this for a long time do you have
anything else that the players can get
excited about you know the mantis is
just a little tease of one of the new
boss fights but there's more to come
right like potentially many boss fights
that we have planned for for the full
release of grounded
there's a lot more secrets and other
things to uncover
when we reached 5 million players i was
already super crazy and then hit the
next milestone of 10 million players
still being xbox doubling it right yeah
in xbox game preview early access that
just goes to show that we have a a
fantastic game everyone's just so
surprised at yeah like how how
how much grounded has grown
i just hope that players and the
community understand how important they
are and impactful on this game with us
you know we're so thankful for
everyone's support along the way it's
been an amazing journey and we're
finally almost at the finish line right
yeah i think we wouldn't be here without
our amazing community and all the fan
support
i agree best community
ever yeah
[Music]
so i got a call from my good friend york
newman the head of microsoft flight
simulator he told me it was imperative
that i meet with him so i'm in this
helicopter we're flying to this location
we're on our way let's go
[Music]
[Music]
york hey paris good to see you good to
see you thanks for coming to this team
man no thank you what am i doing here
later on let's get in we don't have much
time okay
all right first right across the potomac
that's where i'll contact us are we
headed towards arlington it's still
secret
i'm sorry
york
what is this place oh you'll see let's
go
[Music]
wow look at this place
nick how's it going hello
paris i would like to introduce nick
partridge from the smithsonian national
and space museum thank you for having me
but this makes a lot of sense i saw
during the trailer there was a
collaboration between the smithsonian
national air and space museum and flight
simulator here we are at the national
air space museum so let's talk about
that collaboration tell me more about
that well yorg and i have been talking
for more than a year he was looking for
me and it turns out i was looking for
him to ask the same question which was
don't you think that our our
organizations have a lot in common
dedicated to bringing flight to everyone
and uh
i was looking for the spirit of saint
louis which is in the smithsonian ever
since 1928 and the smithsonian was
gracious enough they gave us a
millimeter perfect scan which is what
we'll feature in the 40th anniversary
edition but as nick and i kept talking
it was very clear you know the world's
foremost museum for air and space the
smithsonian
and microsoft celebrating its 40th
anniversary it's a match made in heaven
and there's lots of things we can do
yeah authenticity accuracy access it's
all there we're hoping that if everyone
has as much fun in the community with
the content that we initially
collaborated on a couple of our most
historic aircraft and some of the other
aircraft in this center are already in
the simulator maybe we can jump in with
both feet and do more in the years to
come maybe even who knows we'll go crazy
we'll put the space shuttle in there
oh that sounds amazing
all right you guys have never been here
before this is my first time all right
so uh keep your eyes peeled stick stick
together and uh york i've got something
special for you right around here
perfect
check this out this is my favorite plane
the yonkers u52 3 motor amazing and that
that is an awesome plane and as i look
at all these planes around here it makes
me ask the question
are you going to put all of them in
flight tim maybe not all of them but we
hope a lot of them
in the 40th anniversary that comes out
this fall we already have three we have
the wright flyer the spirit of saint
louis and the dc3 and we hope to get a
few more as nick and i were talking
there's a lot of things we could do yeah
we started with the most iconic ones and
uh who knows there's no lack of
opportunity
you know i keep saying amazing because
this place is amazing and just like
flight sim it just keeps going so what
else is happening it does seem like
we're going supersonic like the concorde
here we've been doing a major update
ever since we launched every month since
august 2020 and just today we're
actually launching world update 10 and
guess what tell me it's the united
states and it's huge we have a dozen
cities a new height field brand new
aerials new missions new airports new
everything and as always
it's free and
check out this beauty this is the
beechcraft model 18 they call it the
twin beach it's a famous plane and
that's also launching today and it's a
great coincidence it's actually a huge
coincidence york's been working on that
beachcraft since before we met but it's
a great example of how much we already
had in common
so yorig what can we expect the rest of
the year from flight zone we have a ton
of great things coming up so today is
world update 10 we have two more world
updates one in august and one in october
and then in november we have the big
40th anniversary edition which will be
an absolute delight for anyone who loves
aviation okay that 40th anniversary
edition tell me more about that yeah so
we're celebrating by bringing back some
of the the planes from the old sims like
from platinum 10 9 8 even before that
and we're restoring some of the old
missions and we're bringing back some of
the airports that were in those editions
so it's a real celebration of the
franchise so this celebration is not
only of the franchise but the past as
well and but also adding brand new
things on top of it like that the
community really wanted for example
helicopters my silver wood a brand new
fluid dynamic system to make all that
work and then we're adding gliders which
is a completely different way to
experience the planet it's just you and
the wind
and then the last one is we bringing
what's the biggest deal for simmers a
brand new real-to-life airliner the a310
from airbus yeah by a brand new partner
called indie builds a great development
team in fact of the 10 planes we're
bringing most of them are created in
collaboration with third parties so it's
a really cool way for us to integrate
with the creator community now how do i
get this if you're on game pass if you
already own flight sim the 40th
anniversary edition is a free upgrade
this has just been an incredible
experience seeing all these planes and
going through the history and everything
that's come in the flight simulator
thank you so much thanks for coming to
dc paris thank you nick for the great
collaboration with the smithsonian and
for kicking off the 40th anniversary
edition of fleissen it's been wonderful
thank you so much thank you
[Music]
today was a good day
but now
i have a need for speed
[Music]
i'm headed to the danger zone basis
[Music]
i came in madrid just yesterday to be
here in fantastic sports and i'm so
excited
[Music]
[Applause]
why gaming
just a passion
[Music]
just the passion that people have
i feel very welcomed
[Music]
hey we're just a snippet of squanch
games and we're here to talk about high
on life our new action adventure comedy
metroidvania first person shooter
that uh is nothing at all
a little bit like microsoft excel all
right you're a bounty hunter now you've
got to help me rescue my friends they're
gatlians just like me
that's our game high on life pretty
insane uh there's a lot to talk about
let's dive in
so justin you're typically known for
working in animation what brings you
into the world of games why are you in
the world of games yeah yeah i i'm
obsessed with games
have been my whole life always had ideas
always had you know things i would love
to make but just never thought i could
ever
step into that arena because i don't i
lack
i lack all the skills needed you don't
know how other than other than like
creative uh direction creative ideas
like like other than that i lack all the
skills to execute but that's why like
that's part of why you want to start
squanch right is like to be able to have
an idea like that and let it grow to
something and and to be able to be
creatively um free i wanted to make
games that i wanted to play and that was
sort of the spark that just
lit the fire of squanch games and then
we shipped trover and we shipped
accounting plus and now we're on
this
absolutely
dream game this is like our real
legit swing at like a proper
you know like we're indie but like this
is like our triple a like yeah or is it
triple i for it for indy we're triple i
yeah yeah this is a triple i game so the
story of our game mostly follows like
earth being invaded by this evil
criminal cartel of aliens who come in
and kidnap humans and start selling them
on the black market like they're drugs
and you're the one human who has to team
up with a talking gun and stop them and
when you select a cartel leader that
you're gonna go after
like
it
opens the the portal door
to that world that they're in eric uh
can you tell us a little bit about the
worlds of the game the art style of the
game the visuals yeah yeah so we spent a
lot of time kind of constructing and
creating these awesome alien worlds uh
myself and uh mikey spano who is our art
director him and i worked like a ton on
the sort of art direction of the game he
really kind of landed in this space
which was kind of
blade runner meets the muppets so we're
trying to capture that feeling with all
of our characters especially our aliens
uh and then each world is its own kind
of unique flavor right i think some of
the ideas came from very kind of core
thoughts like we're like we want to have
an awesome alien like drug den spa on an
asteroid and yeah what makes me really
excited is the sort of really clear
and like it's almost deceivingly simple
narrative right save the earth humans
are drugs talking guns tada so alec what
you know what who are the guns what's
their deal the guns are these talking
alien gatlians um they're all shaped
somewhat like a gun you'd find on earth
but they've evolved to be just gun-like
in their own way and so uh this race of
gatlians each has their own unique
personality their unique set of
abilities and you're gonna be rescuing
them from this evil alien cartel and
together
you gotta stop the bad guys and get more
gatling yeah get more collect more
gatlians yeah a lot of players are going
to have very different experiences
depending on what gun they favor yeah
you kind of pick your favorite companion
to have that a lot and hear their
dialogue be part of different different
different uh dialogue scenes and stuff
yeah look at us blasting away and
sometimes you can unlock the guns in a
different order than another player has
so when you go back through a level
you'll see things that you would have
been able to access if you've done it in
the other order
that's a huge one all right so we've
talked about this crazy good game that
sounds amazing why should people be
excited to play it as a studio we are
attempting to bring
a level
adult comedy into video games something
i love about squanch is we would put a
lot of effort into things that a lot of
other studios wouldn't even bother like
like a single small joke that five
players might find well okay well now
well now i sorta now i can i love that
stuff i love like edge casing and like
that's what makes you remember a game
yeah like if a player is trying to break
the game in a certain way and then you
have an answer for that for them that is
like such a memorable and amazing uh
moment
it's almost like watching tv but the
viewer is able to reach into the tv and
and poke a thing and the character has
to respond to that and there's so much
fun to be had
you can skip it all we worked really
hard on it if you want to skip it yeah
if you want to just like miss out on
like you know if you're like a big dummy
and you don't want to play the game at
all that's fine we're not going to judge
you we're just going to be upset
[Music]
[Music]
this gonna be fun
you know i can't let you leave
um
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
pentiment is a narrative adventure game
set in 16th century bavaria which is
part of the holy roman empire you play a
character named andreas mahler who is an
artist working at a benedictine abbey he
gets involved in a series of murders and
scandals and tries to unravel them over
a period of about 25 years
the name pentiment it is specifically
referring to paintings in which there's
an older painting underneath the
painting that you see on the top and if
you scrape away the top layer you see
what was left behind this has a bunch of
significance obviously you're playing a
painter but also it has a lot of
significance to the idea of history kind
of being covered and uncovered over time
[Music]
when i saw narrative driven games with
really distinctive art styles i was
inspired to make a historical game that
uh focused on the unique art style of
the early modern period that was really
driven by the relationships between
characters and the stories that played
out over time
hannah kennedy was really integral to
defining the art style of pentiment
especially blending
the late medieval illuminated
manuscripts with the early modern
woodcuts
[Music]
yeah so there's a lot of major points to
solve and kind of marry between wanting
this to be a
true to the history true to the
feel of the source material that we were
referencing as far as the narrative but
also thinking about the types of games
that were
like what we imagined we wanted as far
as a gameplay experience
from the beginning i knew that i wanted
to portray
a community that changed over time which
meant that characters are changing over
time that's really the the focus of
everything um the buildings do change
but really it's the characters where you
see all the the crazy stuff happen
kids that i had become attached to
because it's a four-year-old and we
designed them to be a four-year-old and
then they're getting married and then i
felt a weird like emotional reaction to
that because i'm like
oh baby's all grown up
i think the 16th century has always been
really interesting to me because it was
a time of such social upheaval in europe
[Music]
i think when we look at social change in
the past it seems like it's a thing that
always happens outside of our time but
right now i think we're maybe more aware
of than ever that social change is
happening constantly and people are
always struggling with it it's always a
difficult process and so i hope that by
looking at people from the past we can
see that even though the setting might
be different and the specific issues
might be different ultimately we always
struggle with social change
[Music]
it's putting on this antenna
all right let's do crime
it's such a bad idea all you had to do
was keep your mouth shut i'm gonna
override this it's your life mission to
cause harm
this is my favorite shot of the whole
game this one
with as dusk falls what we're trying to
do is to make a brilliant interactive
experience for anyone who loves
brilliant storytelling so people who
enjoy films people who enjoy tv series
it's also a social experience and about
sharing these stories with the people
you love i think we should stick to the
plan yeah stick to the plan i took my
inspiration from tv shows prestige shows
like you know breaking bad fargo i
really love dog day afternoon
it's such a wonderful setup you try that
again and every last one of them leaves
in a body bag when you write for
interactive stories it's all about the
stakes you want big choices the tentful
ones that everyone will remember from
the chapter they played but also you
weave in the smaller stakes the drama
bit like the relationships are you gonna
stay married when you lost your job
this wall went up
and i missed you okay
the game deals with very mature themes
that you don't normally find in a video
game it really gives you agency over
characters that are relatable that are
familiar to you it's like an interactive
story but with the power of video game
behind it i only gotta yell and my
brothers will come
now hold your horses young man
i think you should at least listen to
what i have to say in the first book
it's mainly structured around a hostage
situation in a motel in the middle of
the desert in arizona so it's a pressure
cooker you want your wife to live
answer and do exactly what i say book 2
takes another
approach entirely and it's a chase
across multiple states in the u.s
there's nowhere else to run as those
falls is an interactive show but the
important part here is the word
interactive the players are very much
needed to help the character
on their journey and decide what's going
to happen to them help them grow and
change it's not like there's one golden
path there's so many different ways
through the story you can replay it and
then you get to like different story and
different ending and you feel like
you're actually achieving something and
shaping the story and also the character
some of your true self comes out into
that thinking no no what would you do
i'll try to yeah and at the end of the
game when you play we tell you about
your playstyle and it reveals something
about the player themselves their values
and the way they interact with the
others that they played with
i think for me one of one of the really
important things was that this art style
could tell lots of different types of
stories we want to take really
beautiful sort of subtle facial
performances really strong dramatic
moments and just really represent that
such that every frame is a painting
it's a single player and multiplayer
experience so one to eight players
because we wanted to draw in people
who weren't necessarily gamers gamers
are going to love this game as well
because it's a very mature in-depth
story
but this game really taps into your life
skills rather than your gamer skills
puts everyone on a level playing field
you did well that was a ferocious time
you share the same character
you discuss you make decisions and
majority wins it's like each player is
like a voice in the character's head
it's been a massive journey and
i can't believe we're just like so close
touching distance to this game
yeah i'm gonna miss it when it's done
[Music]
let's check out what mysteries
adventures and of course slimes are
waiting for us in the new vibrant world
of slime rancher 2.
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
too
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right time to get going first trip
in a while put this in here australia
passport i need to pass where's my
passport passport
[Music]
[Music]
all right
where's my uber
all right let's go
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to melvin it is so great to
be here in person get ready for the
showcase
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one two three
[Music]
korea jared melvin with fan fast
[Music]
we are so excited to tell you all about
forza horizon 5 hot wheels the first
expansion for forza horizon 5. so mike
let's start with why the team decided to
bring hot wheels to forza horizon 5's
mexico our fans have been telling us for
years about how much they loved forza
horizon 3's hot wheels expansion so
we've been waiting for the right time to
bring everyone another hot wheels
adventure forza horizon 5 presented the
perfect opportunity to bring hot wheels
to life like never before with the power
of the xbox series x and s it really
does sound like the perfect time for
forza horizon and hot wheels so i'm
wondering if you can tell us a little
bit more about what to expect being in
the clouds of mexico this time yes you
travel to the clouds above mexico to
visit the hot wheels park which is
comprised of over 200 kilometers of the
fastest most extreme tracks yet once
there you'll join the hot wheels academy
and set out to take on forza horizon's
most extreme racing yet and prove
yourself a hot wheels legend let's go
as well as the iconic orange hot wheels
track you'll take on new driving
experiences across gravity-defying
magnet tracks as well as ice water flume
and rumble tracks so we spoke loads
about biomes in the build-up to force
horizon 5's launch are we expecting
something similar in volts horizon 5 hot
wheels as well yes so we're truly going
to see the power of the xbox series x
and s when we look at fort horizon 5 hot
wheels all new biomes the amount of
detail and diversity that we can pack
into the four new biomes is breathtaking
we have the rugged giants canyon where
you'll hear the growl of your engine
bouncing back off the intricately
detailed rock formations the ice
cauldron where frozen tundra drips into
the glistening molten lava in forest
falls you'll see a tree canopy towering
over epic waterfalls and finally the
visually stunning and exhilarating
horizon nexus where the horizon festival
is suspended among a web of hot wheels
tracks and there's more because new
players can jump into fort horizon 5 hot
wheels as early as possible during the
main games initial experience and how
are people going to be able to use event
lab in forza horizon 5 hot wheels so in
event lab you'll have the freedom to
design build and share using the new hot
wheels creation kit that's over 80 new
track and stump pieces that instantly
snap together thanks to our new building
tools you can then share your creations
with the entire community for players to
discover and play we are anticipating
our community building an ever evolving
catalogue of new player-created hot
wheels events that everyone will enjoy
they all sound absolutely incredible
mike but i'm going to ask you the most
important question in the room can you
tell me a bit more about the cars yes so
we have 10 new amazing cars coming to
the pack including
four new hot wheels cars which have been
scaled up to real life proportions we
have the diora 2 the bad to the blade
the baja bone shaker and the chevrolet
hot wheels coppo camaro fort horizon 5
hot wheels introduces the most extreme
tracks we've seen yet in forza so we've
added some new extreme track toys and
hyper cars to go with them
i want to call out the hennessey venom
f5 and the mozler mt900 gt3 their speed
is unlike anything we've seen before so
we know forza horizon 5 fans naturally
love co-op so how is that continuing in
hot wheels so in a first for forza you
can join up with your friends and play
from the very start of the experience in
co-op you and your friends will then
take on a new campaign moving your way
up through faster and faster car classes
until you unlock the extreme speed of
x-class and become a hot wheels legend
you can also choose to take on the world
in horizon open or team up with your
friends to take on a team of drivatars
in the horizon tour oh i absolutely love
that final question now though when can
we expect to play yes so forza horizon 5
hot wheels releases on july 19th on xbox
series xls xbox one windows pc and steam
mike thank you so much for joining me
this has been so much fun and i cannot
wait to play
so
[Music]
ah
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
now on to our next block pun intended of
course minecraft legends is the action
strategy take on the franchise you never
knew you needed i'm here with dennis
reese from mojang studios who has just
released the world premiere trailer of
minecraft legends dennis welcome to the
show thanks for having me malik so happy
to have you i mean this is a really
exciting time for the team let's talk
minecraft as a whole though that game i
have nothing to back this up but i feel
like everyone on the planet's played
minecraft at this point but that wasn't
enough for you all you all went and made
minecraft dungeons and now we're moving
on to the recently revealed minecraft
legends so one tell me a little bit
about what it means for the team to
actually be able to reveal the game and
then two just let us know what minecraft
legends is well we are so excited to
finally be able to talk about this game
with the world we've been working on
this game for some time now minecraft
legends and action strategy game is set
in the minecraft universe
and in order to build this we really
wanted to partner with a great company
that understands strategy games and so
that's when we reached out with
blackbird interactive
and
in doing so we were able to create an
experience
that is uh welcoming for you know people
who may have not played minecraft but
also people who have
and i mean you've seen the trailer it's
about going and traveling through these
beautiful biomes
exploring this world that is familiar
yet still mysterious and so as you
explore these lush biomes you collect
resources and then you use those
resources to to build defenses from
these dangerous but very cute piglens
and uh in those offensive you're able to
to fight them back and send them back to
where they come from and you know what
you're going to probably want to build
some alliances with some unexpected
friends because they're going to help
you actually defeat the piglets and send
them back to where they come from well
i'm looking forward to it and i feel i
love what you said about um trying to
make a game that's both for fans of
minecraft that exist and new fans coming
in minecraft can go in so many different
directions i feel like with a new game
what made you choose action strategy
well really it was a you know many years
ago as a group of folks at mojang
sitting around talking about what game
genres they really enjoy and action and
strategy were were the more popular ones
that came up and so we started to think
about who we could partner with to build
that experience and that's where we we
came into blackberry interactive and
that was back in 2018
and you know the project was codenamed
badger
and uh an interesting little fact for
many of those people that might follow
minecraft if you go back to minecon 2018
and you look at the shirt that jens
berenstein was wearing you'll see a
graphic on there and it's in the shape
of a badger head and really that was
meant to be an easter egg for years for
forward which here we are now and that's
i gotta say i love a good easter egg um
now where would you say that minecraft
legends fits in the overall minecraft
universe well the minecraft universe is
just always growing and expanding and if
it's not from our partner communities
then it's from mojang specifically like
you mentioned uh minecraft dungeons
that's a great example where mojang went
out and we built this dungeon crawler
experience in the minecraft universe and
players love it it's wonderful and with
minecraft legends we're trying to do
something similar really and here we're
going to be introducing a narratively
driven campaign with a whole bunch of
new characters and a lot of other things
that i'm not ready to share right now uh
dennis i thought we were friends i
thought we were friends you can share it
with me and everyone watching
no okay i won't pry any anymore but tell
us when the game is coming out and where
we can keep up to date it's coming out
in 2023 on pc and console on xbox game
pass
and if you want to know more just follow
us twitter or you know jump on
minecraft.net uh dennis i'm so excited
to jump into minecraft legends thank you
so much for stopping by and giving us
the lowdown thanks for having me
what up everybody it's your boy kirsten
aka fondue but we're here at xbox fan
fest we got a whole lot for y'all to
check out so let's get it in
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
they asked me what your halo came out
won this sweet jersey i couldn't believe
when i was here on site that i would get
to meet the real master chief experience
here out of this world it was really
cool to see i'm gonna go get my nails
done because they have a nail station
and these things need to be painted
red fall looks dynamite and come on do
you have a floor oh it's so easy
it's all bloody things no but it's great
i love it
what a day we had today thank you
everybody for showing up to xbox fan
fest toronto had a lot of fun saw a lot
of games great experiences overall
catching the next
[Music]
are
one
[Music]
set it ready
[Music]
[Music]
they got their eyes
[Music]
[Music]
do it like that
i'm joined now by sarah bond who leads
the gaming ecosystem organization here
at xbox sarah it's so great to have you
it is awesome to be here and so good to
see you too yes i'm super excited for
this conversation because as we know
game creators are crucial to xbox's
success and whenever you talk about them
it's with such like passion and tenacity
i love it and it sounds super important
to you and the rest of team xbox so my
question to you is how do creators
inspire the work that you and your team
do
the creators are just the bedrock of
everything we do on my team you know
when you really think about it where
gaming really comes from is it starts
with someone who has a creative idea
that they choose to put into a game that
we all get to experience and enjoy
and that's really the bedrock of our
industry of what motivates us is to help
those people those developers bring
their stories out and we think about it
in three ways you know how do we create
a vibrant and engaging gamer community
for them to come to through xbox what
are the set of tools and services that
we give them that make it easier and
faster and more affordable for them to
make a game and how do we create a range
of business models that they can use
because a business model really enables
them to perform all sorts of different
types of innovation yeah business models
tools resources all these provide
choices and it's increasing these
choices for not only the developers but
the players themselves as well yeah for
example you and your team just announced
a new feature that's going to bring game
demos to players can you tell us a
little bit more about project morecroft
project more crosstalk i know i love
these project names i wish they would
just let me name it but
i know they won't change that
well look we were sitting around as a
team and we were thinking about some of
the things that we've always loved the
most about the gaming industry and one
of them was remember when you would go
to like a show like pax or e3 and you
would go and you go to the show floor
and you get to play a demo or a piece of
a game and the developer will be right
there next to you talking to you about
their experience asking you to try
things out asking your feedback and that
was one of the things i loved the most
about those experiences we just don't
have them as much anymore you know in
the way that the world has evolved and
so we thought gosh how can we make game
pass like that like how can we use the
power of game pass and all of the great
discovery and player engagement that is
in it and have it create for creators
that opportunity to engage with fans
early as they're creating their game and
also for players to get to experience
something that they're really
anticipating and so that's what we're
gonna do we're actually gonna have a
program that enables developers to take
a piece a level of their game and put it
into game pass so they can get that
great feedback and players can engage
with them and we know it's a lot of work
sometimes for developers to do that so
we're also going to compensate them for
their participation in the program i'm
so excited for what's going to come when
we launch that i think the one thing
that we all miss is that connection
right and now that we are able to come
back into conferences and stuff like
that we still need to deepen it because
by deepening that connection you're
diversifying the voices and then that in
return helps to diversify the games and
bring diversity into games absolutely
how will microsoft help to further that
front yeah we think about it all the
time frankly as microsoft as xbox in my
team in particular because creators is
core to everything we do you know if you
think about a game it enables you to
experience a perspective a point of view
in a way that is deep and immersive
unlike any other form of media so the
importance of everyone having an equal
opportunity to share their story in
their perspective through a game and
what it means to shaping our perceptions
to what we talk about what we believe uh
to broaden our perspectives
is critical and we think about that all
the time so what we've done as a team is
we're continuing to expand the set of
developers who were engaging with and
bringing them into the xbox ecosystem we
actually more than doubled the number of
developers that are making games for
xbox and we saw lots of those games in
the last day which has been pretty cool
and the other thing that we did this
year is for the first time ever we
actually have a presence in africa we
have our first xbox employee in africa
specifically dedicated to working with
creators in the region
so what message would you like to leave
for creators who are interested in
starting in the industry yeah i get that
question a lot people say to me gosh i
would really like to get be part of the
gaming industry i'd love to make a game
how do i break through how do i get
involved i say first of all network talk
to people meet people connect with
people just how you and i connected
actually an industry event which we met
at which was super fun you know build
that network and that connectivity
because it's so critical in every
industry but i think particularly in
gaming right you know go to industry
conferences like gdc meet people learn
try that out and if you're interested in
making a game for xbox you can actually
go to github.com you can actually
download the xbox game developer kit and
get started and once you have a game
concept you can also submit it online
through id at xbox.com and then you can
self-publish to xbox which is another
great way and of course if you actually
want to get involved in the industry all
companies are great but i highly
recommend you check out coming to work
at xbox
i'm biased obviously i mean hey you have
so sarah thank you so much for joining
us today and also thank you to all the
viewers for tuning in to extended we've
heard from so many amazing developers on
today's show now before we finish is
there anything else you'd like to share
with us we were talking earlier about
the importance of people being able to
tell their story through a game and how
incredibly powerful it is i mean when we
were talking about that
i was thinking about an experience we've
had as a team that's been very touching
for me
so you know a couple years ago
we started really consciously extending
the depth and breadth of content that we
have in the xbox ecosystem
and it was through that that i got to
know the team making stalker 2 really
well and i actually got to intro that
game last year in the xbox game showcase
and it was just incredible
and you know the thing was when i was
looking at that game last year and i was
looking at the story that they were
telling and they were talking about the
beauty of the land and their dedication
to their culture
and their country and i thought wow this
is a cool game this is a compelling
story
but sitting here today
you know recognizing that that team is
ukrainian they were based in kiev
looking at that story and what they were
showing to the world just feels
entirely different in far more
poignant and visceral to me
you know you you're this is a team who's
talking about their culture
talking about fighting for
the existence of being a nation of being
a people of having their own language
and now we all as a world have gotten to
see
how tenuous that in fact is
and
it's an honor frankly to be part of this
industry and to have the opportunity to
uplift their voices and to let their
story be told through a gaming
experience
especially knowing what we know now
about the situation in ukraine and as
part of that they actually shared with
us something that they wanted us to
share with all of you today as part of
the show
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
so uh
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
uh
[Music]
hello last question dr dallin are you
sure the perimeter surrounding the zone
is really enough
if a powerful emission were to occur we
would listen
the zone has remained stable for years
besides we didn't establish the most
advanced institution in human history
without first guaranteeing its safety
as the head of the scientific institute
for research of the chernobyl area or
circa for short i believe the wonders
that we will bring to the world far
outweigh the potential risks
how big are these risks exactly
the zone reveals a whole new world
we can stick with the old one fearing
change
but tell me
do you want our descendants to remember
us as cowards
or as those who dared to venture forward
to a new better humanity
the injured were evacuated i remind our
listeners that a similar incident
happened in our region quite recently
ruining homes and livelihoods
however city officials urge people to
stay calm assuring them the situation is
totally
[Music]
you